well
[Music]
how are you greetings by cristian casares with
his brief informative on kirchner in
spanish yo padre no hoy became
the 46th president of the usa
where during the inauguration in
washington where carla jefes also
assumed the post of vice president the
ceremony included  the talent of some
artists from las vegas like lady gaga
garth brooks and jennifer lopez who
during the presentation sent a message
to the country in spanish
god indivisible
[Music]
good in southern nevada they also
participated in the moment of
national unity silence to  honor all
the lives lost due to the
coronavirus 29 rays of light illuminated
the interior of the county
building other government buildings such as the
city hall and the airport control tower
they want me were also
illuminated
well the governor solá who offered his
state speech last night where  revealed that
the state's economy suffered a tremendous
blow from the pandemic his plan  to
lift it includes renewable energy
with the creation of innovation zones
that allow new companies to
establish themselves here in nevada the
governor also added to improve the
firing system since it has shown
problems with unemployment
the former president of donald trump
pardoned more than 100 people  during his
last hours as president among
them were he and walters the retired
professional player and recognized in the
history of las vegas' waters was
sentenced to five years in prison for
the use of privileged information the
supermarket is already administering the
vaccine against cob and  tish 9 only
people 70 years of age or older
can be vaccinated at this time and must
do so by appointment online
statewide more than 1,100 new cases were
reported since Monday 8 more people have
died and the total number has risen to more
than 3,800 since  beginning of the pandemic
7 since the deceased are from southern
nevada and now we pass with the forecast
Today is expected to be a
cloudy day with light rain in some
parts of our region the sun will
rise in the afternoon and we will have temperatures in the 60s we are also monitoring a system that will cause rain for the
area over the weekend and
Possibly next week I am a
Christian cancer so this supreme
informative of news now in happy Spanish
[Music]